okay we are at the audit tab of Chrome
developer tools the page I have pulled
up is on code pen it's my zip line for
the random quote generator
this one's get up get up dress up show
up and never give up
that's a quote that I really like so the
audit is really useful it basically
takes a picture of your whole page when
it runs and it walks you through step by
step every way that it thinks you know
using these algorithms it thinks that
your code could be improved so let's see
what happens let's um let's reload the
page and on it on load let's see what
happens okay so I like about this tab it
is so detailed which for me I don't
necessarily know all the complex things
that it's been talking about so far but
these I can understand
so compressing the following resource
with gzip could reduce their transfer
size about two-thirds so that is
something that's network utilization
that's probably on the code pen side so
that's an awesome suggestion to give a
specific thing that you could do to help
and exactly how it would help just
because it's on this audit page doesn't
mean you have to do it but it's
definitely something you should take
into consideration let's look at web
page performance remove unused CSS rule
so that's probably me I probably have
some unused CSS rules that are there
inline block number one sixty percent is
not used by the current page button a
pen author so I'm gonna have to go back
and look at that because if I delete
that it would probably still run just as
well and it would have less code to go
through so it'd be faster and more
efficient use normal CSS property names
instead of vendor prefixed ones that is
a CSS thing that is for code pen that
one's not me but I take full
responsibility for these other ones up
here what I want you to take away from
this audit page is once you have
something up and running just run the
audit it will catch some things than but
maybe you wouldn't have previously
thought of and why you don't have to do
them it might open your eyes to some
things that you weren't aware of that
could really improve the performance of
your page